did you have musicians in your family no
no no I mean everybody kind of sang and
tune and tap their feet and the time but
no no nobody no and when I come from the
the idea of making a career as a
musician or an actor or I mean you know
all they were struggling to put food on
the table that that's that's my earlier
life uh you know I come from nowhere
nothing and you know to wind up like
this it was never I would say my dream
came through but I never even dreamt
that maybe we're all born
with the gifts inside of us and it's
like life is the treasure hunt to see if
you can find it right that's that's
great is it true that you were a CBS
page at the CBS broadcast Center I was I
loved it okay do you know we film our
show at the CBS broadcast Center kidding
can you believe it you are at the
baramore theater and I work where you
used to work every morning every morning
for like three three or four years that
was where I F I I actually played my
first uh grand piano cuz they had a
grand piano in one of the rehearsal
rooms and uh oh my God that moment
hitting the the the the keyboard on a
Steinway piano and they have that in in
one of the rehearsal holes but did it
sound and feel different oh yeah like
coming home well it was fantastic it was
Heaven I was known as the uh as the
piano playing mail boy and whenever I
would finish my mail run I would run
into the rehearsal Hall and everybody
would come all the secretaries and
everybody would come and we would all i'
play and they'd sing and oh it was a
great it was a great job were you happy
there I loved it I love television
people